watch carefully look at that oh boy  [ __ ] delicious oh my lord I decided  to teach a second master class oh boy  this time around I'm gonna take you into  an area where you felt your home cooking  could never go  [Music]  the secret behind any great souffle is  in the buttering of the mold you brush  vertical strokes up this crispy chicken  salad for me is the get out of jail card  especially when you've got a big dinner  party because that is good enough for  four or five of you grab a leaf  lift it up  now I'm fed up when you see chefs  ordering asparagus beautiful you get a  free facial at the same time cooking is  a labor of love stay close to every step  of the way  I'm going to teach you methods secrets  that I'm teaching some of the best chefs  in the world today I'm Gordon Ramsay and  this is my master class  you